one of the philosophical phases that
that I went through I would say in large
part in my undergraduate years but
continuing in a somewhat different way
in my my graduate career when I became
very interested in in semiotics as a
discipline was what I would call my my
logistis phase and by that I don't
necessarily mean the same thing that
that Russell meant along with Whitehead
by the logistics project but but
something along the same kind of lines
and if you're not familiar with that
sort of idea
here's the the basic the basic uh
conception
it was a long-standing idea and I'll
talk a little bit about the history but
in the 20th century that if we could
just
get the the logic and the foundations of
mathematics and then the ways of
modeling right we could we could
conceptualize everything that that was
uh needed to be conceptualized we could
draw new conclusions based on you know
sort of deriving things from the
theorems that we already we already had
and we could attain
complete certainty and predictability we
could we could know things through and
through
and that turned out to be a bust in part
because
um mathematics and logic turn out to to
include a lot more paradoxes than than
we understood and in part that's because
reality is much more complex than this
dream that that people have always had
uh reducing it to a a formal something
that can be represented by a formal
system reality always resists being
reduced to a formal system
and it does so in a number of different
interesting very interesting ways that
are worth um exploring
but there's there's this attraction
that's run through not just the history
of philosophy but let's call it the
history of ideas
in a larger sense so it includes some
people doing mathematics who include
some people doing physics it includes
some people
um engaged in studying human
communication and trying to reduce it
say to cybernetics uh it includes some
people in Psychology you know it
includes a whole bunch of different
things and it goes all the way back if
we had to pick one person to pin it on
it would be Pythagoras this this
Pythagorean idea that everything
ultimately at its basis is not just
modelable by numbers or representable or
or you know able to be manipulated or
conceptualized by numbers but everything
actually is
at its ultimate root in some sense
numbers
and Plato had a somewhat different
conception but there are there are
definitely some Pythagorean elements in
Plato particularly in in some of the
later dialogues this isn't my idea my
own ideas is what some of the scholars
tell us and
um Aristotle and diogenesolarities at
least and what they're telling us about
the platonic school there were at least
some people who thought that reality was
uh or the the you know thing that's most
realism is in fact in some way numbers
and
numbers are kind of a weird thing you
know if you think there's a there's a
whole branch of philosophy called the
philosophy of mathematics and it's
concerned with questions like well what
are our numbers
and you know here's three but is this
the number three as such no because
here's three over here as well and you
know this is also six you know you can
there's all sorts of things to explore
numbers forms are they something that
only exists in our head are they
something that that have to do with the
way we use language there's there's a
lot of different theories out there
anyway that's a bit of a digression
um why did I get into this sort of
mindset that that not only runs from
tenancies and Pythagoras and played all
the way through Descartes and leibnizing
that into
to you know some Modern 19th 20th and
probably 21st century
mathematicians physicists philosophers
other types of scientists
um well it was it was kind of a fluke I
mean for one thing I can I can tell you
this I am in in a certain respect always
a metaphysician at heart
which means that I've always had the
sense that there's more to the picture
than what we see and the ways in which
we're thinking about it and I wanted to
know what the basic you know reality was
not necessarily to pull back the veil
from the appearances as if the
appearances don't matter because
actually my the way I look at things
metaphysically they do in fact matter
quite a bit they have their own type of
reality
um but there was always a sense that
there was something more and that there
was something
not only more but you know in the sense
of some unintelligible surd something
that would just be there and we wouldn't
know much about it but something that
would be intelligible something that was
tailored to to the human capacity once
properly trained to to to know to follow
out our desire for for knowledge
so
I went into the study of philosophy with
that in in mind and
as an undergraduate I've mentioned this
in a few other videos I not only majored
in philosophy I majored in mathematics
and it was kind of a fluke that threw me
into that I didn't think I was very
interested in mathematics
at first as a matter of fact in high
school I was I was a little bit ahead
and so I got placed you know a grade
ahead so I did geometry as a freshman
and then algebra
two trigonometry as a a sophomore
and I think actually I didn't do any
mathematics after that in in high school
I just didn't feel like messing around
with it I'd satisfied my requirements
um
I got placed in a Calculus class my
first semester freshman year and the guy
who taught it Ron Haas
he began by teaching us the theory of
limits and this was mathematics in a way
that I had never seen before
it wasn't just numbers it was explaining
what was going on with what we're doing
with the numbers
the reality that we're trying to model
or
come to understand
because limits themselves are involving
numbers but they're not a number
as a matter of fact a limit is
in a certain sense a lack of number if
you want to think about it that way a
lack of fixity they're they're being
progressively infinitesimally smaller
and smaller amounts until you reach some
number that you know is supposed to be
the limit but the limit isn't really
that
anyway
this got me thinking and you know I'd
been in Geometry before so I was used to
the notion of proofs but they were very
boring in high school just really dull
stuff you know and we just had to
memorize them and we didn't actually do
our own proofs and I you know I
understood the idea of computation and
all that sort of stuff but this was
something very new and then of course
when you know we got interested in the
notion of functions and functions of
functions and the way they worked you
know things were taken to a higher level
of abstraction and many of the other
students didn't like that but I I found
it very engaging
back at that time I had a much greater
capacity for abstract thinking than I I
think I do now
I also had the sense of what we call
mathematical intuition which is very
important if you're going to progress in
in higher level mathematics
which I
don't necessarily think I have now I
don't push myself when it comes to that
so anyway I I like that so much I took
calculus 2 and then I took calc 3 and
then I said well hey I may as well
become a math major and I just kept
taking math class after math class after
math class
and
at the same time in philosophy and I
took intro and then the next semester
after that I took ethics and logic and
then I began taking the historical
sequence and logic I really enjoyed you
know this is sort of again a function of
where I went to school
there was this sense that well the
history of philosophy it's just kind of
a bunch of problems and people have said
different things about it here and there
but nobody really has arrived at any
sort of satisfactory conclusion so you
just kind of figure it out as you go
along and pick and choose what you like
and it was that way in just about
everything except for logic
with logic
there were there was a progressive
building we used kopi's logic textbook
which is a pretty standard one
and you can cover more and more and more
and more and build in a kind of not
necessarily scaffolding way but almost a
cyclotic way higher and higher until you
can address more and more stuff
that fascinated me and
we are fortunate enough to have for one
reason or another quite a quite a few
works on logic and the foundations of
mathematics and things like that in our
library so I I read through those and I
saw how you could you know apply
modeling over here and you know maybe
there could be a logic of you know
uh Heim or there's there's a logical
structure to moral life or you know
modality you know
all these sorts of things that people
were doing that were quite interesting
with logic
um pretty much everything that I was
studying was uh what we call Modern
logic you know uh late 19th and early
20th century all the way to the you know
70s and 80s kind of stuff
and I thought there was uh quite quite
you know interesting and and
um
I think you know when it came down to it
for me it was it was uh you know we make
a distinction in philosophy between the
theoretical and speculative
you know where somebody wants to know
something for the sake of knowing that
thing not necessarily because there's
any application and then the Practical
where we're concerned with what it is
that we can do or what we ought to do or
how things how things actually do in
fact happen so we can manipulate them or
change them or make them go go a certain
way
and I was very much interested in these
things from a speculative point of view
not from a a practical point of view
which is a nice luxury back then and I
think part of what attracted me
so much to mathematics and to logic and
thinking that you could extend this into
everything was two two qualities that
that mathematicians strive for what is
rigor one is being able to you know
rigorously lay out
what it is that's supposed to be going
on and you know show somebody step by
step by step if they understand the
concepts they ought to be able to to
understand the conclusions that you're
arguing for or arriving at
um and then there's Elegance this is a
bit harder to put your your finger on
and Define but there's there's a kind of
Elegance to mathematics and to logic
that is very attractive
there was also this promise that that
by going further and further and further
into this sort of thing and by by
accepting the postulate that these could
be extended in theory to to just about
every type of reality that these would
make reality fully intelligible and that
was that was probably I would say my my
greatest desire at the time
um still is a desire I just have a
different way of approaching it now
and
so I you know like I said I majored in
mathematics and I took you know various
classes I went through calculus uh as
far as the sequence went and uh
then we got it you know I don't remember
the exact sequence of what we did but we
did linear algebra which is very nice
because you work with these matrices and
you can use them to model things it's
very useful for Logistics problems
um also good for Game Theory and uh
linear algebra was really interested in
and whether they've talked number theory
in particular I was I was very
interested in because that showed me
that even if you changed the system that
you were working with you could you
could in theory model
mathematics upon mathematics
that's probably not the best way to talk
about it but that that was the basic
Insight that you can map these things on
to each other
I also found particularly interesting
um
some of the other things like like
probability
statistics I was less interested in you
know compiling statistics for its own
sake and more interested in the theory
of probability what was actually going
on with that and I started looking at
wow these assumptions that we have to
make in order to make this this sort of
stuff work and I was particularly
interested in this this field that we
call the foundation of mathematics which
is really working with with logic and
Mathematics is based on on logic
and so you know if you can understand
that stuff then you can you can
understand what it is that we're really
doing with mathematics
um
so I I was in I was very deeply into
that and I'll just tell you a little bit
before I tell you about how I got out of
it I'll tell you and actually I'm going
to show you I've got some props here's a
sort of typical representative work uh
uh luche and raffias games and decisions
um very old you know Game Theory
textbook I loved this stuff because you
know it's it's it's uh working out you
know Bit by Bit by Bit the theory of
games of strategic decision making uh
meaning decision making that you have to
engage in when the other person over
there is also engaging in similar stuff
and how do you model what's going on in
their head and how it affects what's
going on in your head just you know very
interesting stuff
um
I ended up writing my my senior thesis
on Truth self-referential statement
groups and I I I'm assuming that it
still must be a Lakeland College
somewhere
um in the library
I I don't have a copy of it I don't know
what you know that's several computers
ago so I don't I don't have any idea
what's become of it
um
not even sure what I wrote it in
originally
and
I got interested in this question of the
Liar's Paradox you know the Liar's
Paradox is very simple
there's a couple different variations on
it there's you know epimedes the cretan
says all cretans are liars so you know
if he's lying that means that he's
telling the truth if he's telling the
truth it means that he's lying you've
got this back and forth sort of thing
and I got interested in larger sort of
networks where you might have a couple
people talking about who's telling the
truth and who's lying
um and there could be there could be
some cases where
what they were saying was actually
self-referential and then there could be
some cases where it was just referential
to you know the other guy and then the
other guy refers to them and I thought
well how can I model this and so I came
up with a functional uh way of modeling
it
and I showed that all truth
self-referential statement groups if all
we were dealing was truth
self-referentiality boiled down to the
Liars Paradox or to something that's
sort of like a tautology you know this
this Loop where it's something
everything is true everything is is
false
and
that was kind of interesting I excluded
a lot of pragmatic considerations like
the degree of probability that you would
ascribe to somebody or if it was in
terms of other modalities like you know
a person being good or bad or reliable
or unreliable
um
and and I did that in order to make it a
simpler process
um
but you know in theory it could be
extended out to other things like it's
very complicated very quickly once we
start dealing with with these sort of
Logics that are not just of Truth and
falsity
um
so I did that and I you know that was
that was my senior project and then when
it came time to write a uh application
paper for graduate school this is the
weirdest thing I've ever done and I'm
I'm just so surprised that I got
accepted at quite a few places
um what I actually did was I said well
you know and I'd been thinking about
this for a while I realized that a
geometrical modeling of this
um this thing for the Liars Paradox that
a lot of Truth suffer self-referential
statement groups boil down to was
actually the the movieist band and I'd
done a lot of playing around with them
and you know pasting strips of paper
together and doing twists and and things
along those lines in case you don't know
what a movie strip is is a it's a ring
of paper or anything else that you like
and you give it one half twist so it's
actually only got one side to the entire
thing and what this means is that
graphically or or you know
topographically uh the Liars Paradox is
is uh equivalent to a one-sided figure
where what appears locally to be truth
is on the other side locally falsity but
where it's all really the same thing and
so that's what I submitted a three-page
discussion of that
by then I was really getting out of that
and um let me talk about why I I ended
up leaving this this sort of dream of
the logistics project behind and again I
have I have a bunch of props a bunch of
books that sort of fit in with this
two of these really have to do with um
uh mathematics and philosophy
per se
and one of them that I came across was
wittgenstein's remarks on the
foundations of mathematics and I'd read
some Wittgenstein as an undergraduate
and I thought the stuff was very
interesting
and when I got to this this is the nice
one it's got the German on one side in
English on the other this I was like wow
I didn't I didn't know that he actually
talked about this and Wittgenstein was
very interested in trying to figure out
what is it that we're doing when we're
doing mathematics and he thought of it
in terms of of language and how we
actually use language to understand the
world he didn't begin from mathematics
and then say well language is going to
be you know
mathematizable or model you know able to
be modeled through mathematics he's
actually going the other way around he's
doing a radical shift and saying no
language is actually broader and
Mathematics and what can be dealt with
in terms of mathematics is actually just
a portion of of our world and of our our
language and our our existence as
communicative beings so that was that
was something that you know really gave
me pause another thing another book that
actually we did a math class it was a
special seminar just on this we went
through the entire work this is a big
book in the 1980s and 90s girdle Escher
Bach and wonderful wonderful book
what it's dealing with
the entire book is trying to think about
Artificial Intelligence on the one hand
and also trying to think about Kurt
Goodell's incompleteness theorem
and
to be very simple about it Kurt
Goodell's incompleteness theorem says
that when it comes to any formal system
the mathematics itself is a formal
system logic is a formal system anything
that you can you can do with them is a
formal system
um you can have it one or two ways but
you can't have it both
either you can have a very
strong system
very rigorous system
but then there's going to be a lot of
things that that end up getting left out
or you can try to make it as complete as
possible but then you're going to have
inconsistencies you're actually going to
have some contradictions arising within
it and you got to pick one or the other
because you can't you can't actually
have it both ways
um you can't have both of the things
that you want to have which is complete
you know complete rigor and complete
applicability or extensibility however
you want to think about it
um and I'm you know paraphrasing very
roughly here I understand this is not
the exact language of grudel's and
completeness Theorem you can supply that
yourself that's quite all right
and in any case
um
what this led me to realize was that
there were these paradoxes
deep within the heart of mathematics and
logic that you would never be able to to
get rid of that you would never actually
end up overcoming and that that was
integral to the very nature of the way
mathematics interfaced with with reality
that was in the heart of of mathematics
and I began to understand this this book
again is very good for pointing this out
that
part of what constitutes intelligence
is actually being able to get past what
it is that formal systems allow us or
make possible
now another thing that helped sort of
break me out of my Logistics phase was
existentialism in particular sart I was
very big on sart and this is his you
know Master early work being a
nothingness of course this isn't the one
that I had at the time I had the bigger
volume with
the guy depicted on the front but this
is what I have nowadays and
with existentialism at least archery and
existentialism
there were there were a couple things
that were reacting against this logicist
idea one was that this this view that
um
look what's really most important tends
to be individual tends to be
existentials tends to be stuff that
we've lived it's not stuff that's
susceptible to being put into a
universal framework or language it
resists that and when we try to push it
into that it deforms it and we lose it
in the process
um another thing that was really you
know important for again for breaking me
out of this
was the realization that
let's say we live in a deterministic
universe
we would still have free will according
to sart
and I was a hardcore satrian for a while
I mean you can look at my my video about
my satrian phase one of the things that
I really liked the most about start was
his emphasis on our radical Freedom even
if we're in a situation that is
completely deterministic we still choose
what attitude that we're going to take
or we're going to adopt towards our what
he calls our Factory so
the other thing that I would say
help me work my way out of this this
logistis phase and into what I think are
more productive ways philosophical ways
of doing things happen to be a short
story writer and poet
um who had a deep interest in
metaphysics
in language
and in
mathematics and that is Jorge Louis
Borges this is the the book of the first
book of his that I I bought Labyrinth
and you know this is a great volume
because it has
has some of his his best stories in
there and it's got a lot of essays too
which are interesting like uh of course
the garden of forking paths my favorite
one is actually the lottery at Babylon
and maybe I'll do a video sometime about
why I like that better than almost any
of the other ones but you know the
circular ruins another one of my big
favorites the library of Babel a lot of
people you know are very interested in
that one because you know Jorge says I
imagine that paradise would be like a
library
um
three versions of Judas that's a really
interesting one
the story of the warrior and the captive
the house of hysterian it's just full of
great stuff
what Borges was really interested in in
doing was
thinking in terms he's very leibnizing
thinking in terms of a universal
language that could in fact express
everything and allow us to connect
everything up together in
intelligibility and his stories are are
explorations of how the very nature of
reality and language undoes that
generally through making things even
more complex and complicated
you could think of what Borges is doing
in
um
in literature as prefiguring
mathematical chaos theory not the you
know depiction of Chaos Theory saying in
Jurassic Park or you know
popularizations but
but there's no also you know there's
there's a there's a great book out there
called the mathematics of meaning that
ties Borges to uh catastrophe Theory and
what he's pointing out are again these
these is very similar to what's going on
with with um girdle Asher Bach and also
you know Wittgenstein
that there are paradoxes
inherent to the very nature of the
interface between mathematics and
reality and we are that interface too by
the way
um the human person the human being
endowed with Will reason intellect
developable fallible
um we are where that that takes place
human being
um
so all these things pushed me out of
this this this notion which would say we
can take mathematics and make reality
and make and make human beings
fit into
the structures of mathematics and logic
in a a way that would resolve everything
that would make everything intelligible
that turns out to be an impossible dream
that's not to say that mathematics is
not of just amazing
extension and usefulness and and Beauty
in many respects
um
it just doesn't do what what some of the
dreams that people have had like
Descartes or
at one time Bertrand Russell had them or
or myself
so that's that's another little chapter
in my my philosophical development maybe
you found it interesting maybe it uh
doesn't really have much to do with the
way you're doing and in your
philosophical studies but there it is